all right good afternoon everybody wow I
can hardly see any of you now projectors
right my face can get the house lights
just a bit perfect thank you all right
good afternoon my name is Judy de haan
I'm going to give you a nice kind of
after lunch not too mentally taxing
presentation where it's loosely titled
to own the future ultimately looking at
certain trends that have been happening
in the industry in the world and how
that effects us as software developers
the companies that we're working in how
we should take that into account in
terms of the management of software
projects the team structures the
software architecture that we do and
from there if this kind of stuff is
interesting for you then there's another
talk later on this afternoon that goes
much more into the nitty gritty details
of how you actually implement all the
stuff that were gonna be talking about
over here so starting with the sort of
the big interesting trend that I think
that most of us in software development
have been largely ignorant of because we
don't really watch this dark market but
something big has changed if you look at
the average company life lifetime on the
S&P 500 which is the index of the 500
largest companies 500 largest public
companies over the years what we see is
this trend that companies used to be in
that fortune 500 if you will for on an
average of 30 years and decade by decade
that has whittled down to the point that
we're somewhere in the area of 10 to 15
years and it doesn't look like that
trend is stopping in other words the
world is becoming much more dynamic and
companies that used to be at the top are
not anymore
and many of them have just been totally
wiped out and more of that seems to be
happening and executives and various
large organizations are kind of wringing
their hands over that because you know
their bonuses are tight
stock performance and those types of
things it doesn't really affect us
directly as software developers but it's
important to realize that there that
there is this trend happening and if we
look at it this is around the same time
that computers started to come into the
world so computers in terms of just
information technology and the speed at
which information moves across the world
are creating massive changes and the
world's biggest companies the Facebook's
the apples the googles the Amazons they
didn't exist
20 30 years ago and although now we kind
of look at them and say well you know
Facebook is enormous and Amazon is
enormous and they're not going anywhere
anytime soon
those were exactly the same things that
people said about the previous batch of
really big companies in their day so
there's this fairly well-known venture
capitalist his name is Marc Andreessen
and he put out this quote saying
software is eating the world in all
sectors in the future every company will
become a software company or essentially
will go out of business and he's given a
bunch of different examples here are 3d
printing in terms of where it started
and where it is today where really the
entire manufacturing sector of how parts
get created from sort of big batch type
of creations to small ad hoc whenever
you need a types of things and just
about every field imaginable is being
reinvented by software the companies
that we hear about today Netflix
something that didn't exist ten years
ago the idea of being able to watch in
high-definition
any bit of TV movie whatever you know in
in your pocket at any point in time was
unthinkable now the the story about this
software eating the world a lot of us
are operating in enterprises in a bunch
of different domains whether that's
healthcare or finance or retail and each
one of these areas has kind of been
gradually affected by
they're sort of a boiling the frog
effect where there's big change
happening but because it's happening
over the span of five to ten years most
of the companies are still kinda
deer-in-the-headlight see looking around
kinda saying well it looks like my peers
aren't really doing anything so we'll
open up an Innovation Lab we'll do some
exploration around blockchain who's got
some blockchain crazy going on in
their company okay good
oh yeah one hand goes up so it's usually
at that level of sort of a token
innovation type thing of yeah we're
doing a Aitu without anybody really
knowing what AI is and most of the
companies out there even though this
massive trend is upon them that idea of
fundamentally reimagining themselves as
a software company as an information
company hasn't really trickled in most
of us in software development feel this
all the time
you got the business stakeholder saying
you know just do this just build me this
project we don't really have a seat at
the decision-making table and you know
we do what we need to do but the
organization itself doesn't really view
IT as something SuperDuper critical to
all of their decision-making where most
of that it's business as usual
now this idea that software is eating
the world that companies will become
software companies you know those
statements ultimately imply a fact that
software fundamentally requires a
different perspective from all the other
things that have been going on in
business environments now again as
software developers we kind of
intuitively get that but we're not
really good at explaining that to
business stakeholders so most business
stakeholders again the treat software
pretty much just like every other
project that they might be running in
the organization so whether it's a
construction plan or whether it's a new
product
that they're looking to get out in terms
of manufacturing the big difference and
we're talking about software is that
unlike other business projects a
software project isn't ever really done
in the sense that you know you do a
software project and then it's in
maintenance mode we'll talk about that
maintenance mode for just a second but
the way that most business executives
treat software is just more of the same
and part of the issue is that I think
for us as software developers we're in a
good position to explain to the rest of
the organization why it should be
different but a lot of times and I've
spent you know probably north of a
decade talking to companies all over the
world specifically the software
developers all over the world and what
I've noticed is we often lack the words
we lack the ability to explain in
business terminology what is different
and why things should be handled
differently and that's what I hope to
transfer to you in this session is not
just you know the things that you
intuitively know but how to explain them
in order to effect change for the rest
of the organization so let's start with
the lifecycle of a software project or a
software system where somewhere in the
beginning you get some business
stakeholder that comes along and says
eight I have an idea just build me this
little app I need these three and a half
use cases and can you get it done by the
weekend and you're like dude it's Friday
afternoon between what we this weekend
do you mean I know no it's really simple
I saw this add-on you can kind of build
your own website in 15 minutes so I
figured that it might take you you know
five or ten minutes because you're
better than you know the people that are
using Wix or whatever other type of
draggy dropped the environment and
you're thinking to yourself okay this is
gonna end bad right every single time
you get this sort of rush order to build
software it ends up going bad so you get
them to swear two ways from Sunday that
it won't have to scale and that the code
you know it's gonna have some bugs in it
and
that you know if you try to throw more
complexity at it I'm gonna have to
rewrite it just build it so you put all
those caveats in place and you start
working on this thing and as you're
working this thing okay so you're gonna
hit that date than you're like mmhmm
maybe like well keep at it
so you're working working working and
then like oh I forgot to tell you I need
this other use case as well oh my god
but you're gonna still meet the deadline
right I don't know I'll try so you keep
at it of course you miss the original
deadline right because you're only human
and there's 24 hours in the day
so eventually some period of time goes
by and you kind of sort of cobble the
thing together and it kind of sort of
works and you show it to the users and
they're like oh okay this is awesome
let's go start using this everywhere
like wait a minute did I not say that it
doesn't scale did I not say that it's
not going to be able to handle the load
and all the caveats but at that point in
time it's already out of our hands and
off the business runs with it now
officially during this period of time
the software's in maintenance mode right
you finished the project you delivered
it so now it's officially in maintenance
so what does maintenance look like for
software so let's think about that they
come to you to say look there's this bug
you know it doesn't work the way that I
want it to work can you fix it so that
kind of makes sense maintenance equals
bug fixes now quick question let's just
have a show of hands who thinks it's
easier to fix bugs when the system is
live and in maintenance mode versus who
thinks it's easier to fix the bugs while
the system is still in development
before it's live and not in maintenance
mode
all right so easier to fix in
maintenance I don't see any hands going
up okay
easier to fix and development before the
systems live okay all the hems are going
on all right another question for you
when the systems in this maintenance
mode they come to you say hey we could
really use this other feature could you
build this other type of report that
would show XY and Z okay I guess I can
kind of do that so you go build that
again question for you is it easier to
build a new feature when the system's
live being used by actual people on real
production data in maintenance mode or
is it easier to add the feature when the
system is still in development and not
live so who says easier to add the
feature while the systems in maintenance
no hands going up who says it's easier
to do it while the system's still in
development all the hands going up
excellent so explain to me how it is
that we've decided that there's a whole
other class of programmers that are
called maintenance programmers who are
usually the more junior and the less
skilled of the programmers in the
company when they're supposed to do the
work that we just defined and all agreed
unanimously in this room is the much
more difficult work anybody got an
answer to that I've heard one and it's a
really good answer but the problem is
that I'm being recorded so just promise
that you don't share the recording with
any managers all right this will be our
little secret the reason that we have
these maintenance programmers that are
more junior and less skilled doing the
harder work is maintenance programs no
it's not fun right we love building
things from scratch
being creative imagining new ways in
which to design stuff dealing with
crummy legacy code
kind of inconsistent data and databases
that needs to be cleaned up and users
that are still using the system oh that
is no fun pass that on to the junior
people I mean when I was a junior
programmer I had to put in my time right
I had to do that crap work now it's my
turn to have fun and the rest of the
junior guys they don't put in their time
and when they become a senior developer
tech lead architect whatever then they
get to do the fun stuff as well and then
somehow
collectively as an entire industry even
though nothing that I've said is
surprising to any of you here after this
process kind of goes on year after year
and you can get junior programmers that
are kind of just in over their head and
they kind of make a little bit more of
the mess here and they kind of break
something over there that after two or
three or four years the mess becomes so
big and it takes so long to deliver any
new features on that big ball of mud
that one of us senior people has brought
back in to try to figure out what's
going on and we look at the mess and say
you know what I think it would be faster
to write the system from scratch then to
make the system do what it is that you
want it to do on top of the existing
code base who said that before be faster
to write the system from scratch yes
lots of hands going up now just a quick
poll all right for those who say they
would be faster to write the system from
scratch have had that experience was
that analysis done in sort of a rational
dry unemotional spock-like
you know weighing of pros and cons and
costs and benefits and all that kind of
stuff or was it just kind of a plea for
help a cry of exasperation and
frustration so who says the spark
rational yes I've analyzed
yes I've got three or four hands there's
always some of the difficult worm that's
it yeah yeah I did that I thought about
it properly the rest of us aren't lying
to ourselves right
it was just frustration the whole
rewrite it because oh right now let me
tell you something about rewrites but
really quickly who's on a rewrite
project okay some hands are going up I
have some really bad news for you so
brace yourself all right
rewrites and why they go wrong so
there's this thing called the Iron
Triangle of time scope and resources so
when going to do a rewrite
generally speaking the idea is okay
we're going to stop
maintaining the existing big ball of mud
and we're going to divert all of our
resources to rewriting it in essence
there's this implicit agreement between
IT and the business we're gonna stop in
business you're just gonna have to wait
while we rewrite this thing but believe
us it's going to be so much better the
problem is time right there at the top
because you see the business is only
willing to kind of sit on ice for so
long make it a year year and a half if
you're kind of pushing it but that's
just about as long as the businesses
willing to wait and not get any benefits
to its existing running systems while
you're writing things from scratch now
you're thinking to yourself II do a lot
of new year a house especially
resource-wise if I get all of the
programmers in the company helping me
and working on this thing and you're
thinking to yourself well if we just you
know DDD this thing and we BDD it and we
TDD it and we just keep throwing D's at
the thing eventually you know it will
succumb to our architectural vision and
we will have a beautiful
Christene new system that everybody will
love working on now usually the first
three to six months this belief is able
to kind of persist but around that point
in time various business stakeholders
kind of drop by and say hey I heard
you're rewriting the X system you know
there's this feature I've been dying to
have forever and I've always been told
that you can't put it in because the
system wasn't architected for it but now
because you're re are connecting
everything can you put this new feature
and it's really important you're
thinking oh well how can I say no
right because that's kind of the whole
point of this rewrite on the rear
architecture is to be able to support
the new requirements and the new
features that the business wants you're
like okay I think we can get that in
there and then you get another business
stakeholder and this scope creep starts
happening so all of this on top of the
fact that it took the business five to
seven years to create the big ball of
mud in the first place and now you need
to write it from scratch with all of the
existing functionality plus the extra
crap that they keep throwing your way in
a year and a half I gotta tell you the
math just doesn't really add up and
again somewhere around that six to nine
month point you get that sinking feeling
that we're not gonna make it
we just there's just too much to build
and then all those Dedes they just go
out the window we got to be pragmatic I
love it when developers use that word
pragmatic is a fancy way of saying do
dumb fast right we've got to be
pragmatic because we got to get this
stuff done on time so all of the
beautiful ideas about how this new
architecture is going to be flexible and
maintainable and scalable and all the
bubbles
you know what the what comes after bull
right that's what ends up happening to
our system so we just keep just banging
away at it making a mess trying to stand
up one feature after another feature and
after another feature after a
year-and-a-half the business is like
sorry we can't wait anymore
we need some developers back to go and
maintain the existing systems because
we're dying here so now you start losing
developers when you're already late for
the delivery of the thing and now the
big ball of mud that you were looking to
replace you're now chasing a moving
target with fewer developers than you
had originally this does not end well
and you're thinking I know like no it
ends much worse than that because you
see by the time that you actually have
something that you're ready to deploy
one of the things that you didn't take
into account is that most of the time
you weren't able to replace all of the
functionality of the legacy system you
replace some of it but because of the
scope creep you've added a whole bunch
of features but you didn't replace some
others and now you want to go live with
it but the business is saying yeah but
we still need those old features we
can't stop using them you're like okay
but now we got to deploy the new system
alongside the old system we need to run
them side by side
that was never in scope I never thought
about how I'd need to do two-way data
synchronization between the new system
and the old system and that's the moment
when you kind of realize pol bad is
just starting to happen because you
start trying to figure out how to do
this data migration from the old to the
new and data synchronization back from
the new to the old while users are using
them both at the same time and it's a
whole other project
just to kind of get the two systems
talking to each other and you're writing
just the help the most hellishly ugly
code trying to get things working
because the business has totally lost
patience with this one and a half a year
rewrite project that is now into two and
a half years going on three and at this
point in time you've created just about
the worst black hole of coupling that
anybody could imagine and finally you
get this thing kind of sort of working
and the users are kind of complaining
that they have to do swivel-chair
integration between you know a window in
the new system in the window in the old
system and you're swearing to yourself
never again and then that that that sort
of clump is it Frankenstein system
continues limping along and maintenance
for another couple of years until some
new senior developer Technical Architect
is brought into the company and looks at
this big gigantic ball of mud and says
you know that feature that the business
wants I think it would be faster to
write this whole big ball of mud from
scratch rather than implement the
feature on top of this big mess and at
that point in time you're a little bit
older and far wising to say forget about
it I've been through a rewrite it's not
as glamorous as you think and the end
badly
often times the reason we have the
current big gigantic ball of mud is a
result of you know roughly every five to
seven years somebody new coming into the
organization trying to do a rewrite only
this time it's with a new database
technology only this time it's with a
new programming language only this time
it's running in the cloud rather than
on-premises every time we got some
technological excuse why this time it's
going to be different anybody remember
the the the good old days of the just
when dotnet came on the scene and
we did the the dotnet rewrite of the
crappy VB system who was through one of
those yes yeah I see a bunch of hands
going up and then who was there when
roughly five years later we rewrote all
of the XML web services with WCF yep
hands going up right and then roughly
five years after that when we threw away
all the WCF and replaced it with web api
and God knows what else came out of
Microsoft yeah and entity framework
right that was the new batch of stuff
and thrown away the old ORM s so we've
been through this rodeo a couple of
times but for some reason the idea of a
rewrite that's going to solve everything
it just never dies it's always some new
batch of programmers that are coming in
all wide-eyed and optimistic they're
saying this time it's gonna be different
so there actually is a different way to
handle this but it's not through
rewrites it's by thinking about software
not as a project but rather as a
long-lived product and I know that kind
of sounds like just over a play on words
but the difference is that a project is
something that is meant to be completed
and not really touched again whereas
products when you think of them sort of
from a business perspective think of the
iPhone think of the Prius think of
really any type of product that you
might be using when Apple put out the
iPhone they were not saying to
themselves we're gonna put out this
amazing new phone it's gonna be awesome
everybody's gonna love it and then we
just won't make any changes to it ever
again
right it's insane the idea of a product
is a long-term commitment to a future
stream of enhancements to that thing
anytime we're building custom software
we're in essence building a product
rather than a project it is meant to be
something that will be enhanced
and grow for ideally forever if we do it
right and the problem is that we use a
management construct which is the
project which totally screws up that
longevity of the product that we're
trying to create now the idea of a
product rather than a project is that
you know you got the iPhone one then you
got the iPhone two then you got the
iPhone 3 there will be drops along the
way but the whole idea is knowing that
when we do this release that's not the
end of it we will want there to be
continued but stable investment for the
foreseeable future we don't want the
cost of developing the new version to
end up being so high that we need to
scrap everything and start from scratch
so that's the idea of product thinking
it's this iterative delivery of value of
saying look you know we got this v1 it
gives you something it's not great but
it works and then sometime after that
you put out a v2 and sometime after that
you're putting out v3 but that the idea
is there is no such thing as maintenance
the maintenance programmers and the
people that are rigidly designing the
software they're the same people and
ultimately the junior people are working
with the senior people the less skilled
people are working in teams with more
skilled people where we maintain that
knowledge over time of how do we do the
next thing and how do we do the next
thing and we never lose sight of where
we're trying to take this product so
when we're starting something out we
need to realize yeah I mean yeah it's
just this little sapling now it's just
this you know tiny little thing but we
want to grow it into something
significant we need to invest not just
us as software developers but the
business mentality around it for the
long term while making sure that our
short-term execution is proper so that's
all of your DVDs and BD DS and CD DS and
DD's right all of that kind of stuff you
need to do that kind of stuff properly
now what does that actually mean so I'm
kind of telling a nice story but
ultimately the problem here wasn't ever
us as software developers we've wanted
to do the right thing but the management
constructs around us a lot of times they
didn't allow us to do the right thing so
really it's not just a software
development issue it's not that we
didn't use the right technologies or we
didn't use the right patterns ultimately
organizations that want to survive into
the future will need to rethink the
traditional management structure which
is often you know same type of group of
older folks that have been around for
quite some time and kind of been doing
the business thing for decades and
really just kind of looking at let's
keep doing things the way that we know
how so I don't want to talk about how to
change the whole executive management of
the company that's not the topic of what
we're talking about today but at a much
more practical level how do we actually
figure out what to build and how to
build it
all right so starting up with the
requirements what to build so I got some
interesting news for you the business is
not actually capable of giving us
requirements now you might be thinking
okay exactly the problem is that when
the business stakeholders come to us
with requirements in essence what
they're doing is they're giving us a
workaround that they came up with for
the constraints of the existing systems
so there's something that they want to
achieve and the systems are kind of
getting in the way now like you know if
we add another column over here I'll use
that field and that workflow over there
and we put that in that calculation over
there and it comes out on this report
that'll do what I want and then they
come to us and they give us
as requirements those aren't
requirements that's a workaround in
essence they're doing the design for us
and you know what they're not really
qualified to do design but we sort of
take that at face value when we go build
exactly what it is that they asked for
we keep doing that over and over again
and then we end up with a big ball of
mud so we need to nip that right in the
butt and that's what this business
analyst role is there for now I'm going
to talk in just a second what is special
about this role different from maybe the
business analysts that you have in your
organization but the main thing that is
important about a business analyst is
that they have the stature and political
capital in the organization that when
the business says hey build X that they
could say you know I hear you but I
think that there might be another couple
of other ways to achieve what it is that
you want so let's start having a
conversation what if we did it this way
what if we did it that way would that
solve your problem oh that solves half
of your problem well what's the other
half you want someone who can have this
push back and have this back and forth
without the business coming in saying
just shut up and build what I told you
to and that's the problem with business
analysts in many organizations today is
that they don't have that stature they
don't have that ability to get the
business to listen and engage in a
conversation on what the actual problem
is eventually business analysts need to
be able to translate that workaround
into a sort of a business objective what
it is that you're trying to achieve
making something better cheaper faster
usually that sort of it's one of those
three you're all over the three that
business is looking for if you can't
figure out based on what they've asked
from you what is going to be appreciable
better cheaper faster for the
organization your miscommunicating now
once you can get that then the business
says exactly that's what I want to
achieve that's the whole point of this
exercise then congratulations you still
don't have a requirement now you at
least know what might possibly be
required provided that it's not too
expensive and this is where estimation
comes in now you might have heard
there's this movement out in the world
called no estimates call on it
will explain why estimates aren't really
the problem its estimation as a process
that we're not very good at so the first
thing to realize is estimates aren't
promises big problem in most
organizations they ask you for an
estimate and you're like I think it's
gonna take six months when you end an
estimate with a question mark usually
not a good sign kind of thinking I think
it's gonna take longer but if I say
longer you're not going to let me do it
so I'm just sort of trying to mentally
telepathically read what would be an
acceptable number so that I don't end up
looking like an incompetent programmer
well at the same time not low-balling it
too much because I still have to build
it in that amount of time right so part
of the no estimates movement is saying
that yeah that's kind of dumb let's stop
doing that that doesn't work but it
doesn't really come up with a better
answer thing so how exactly do you do
estimates so here's the thing I'm gonna
give you the secret sauce of estimation
how to do estimates number one given a
well formed team of a certain size well
formed meaning not just a random bunch
of people that have never worked
together before because if you just grab
a random group of people that haven't
worked together before it isn't entirely
clear that they're actually going to be
able to work together well and you're
gonna have to spend a bunch of time
turning them into a team and it's kind
of hard to know that can take a month is
that gonna take three months is that
just never going to happen because the
personalities are just too volatile with
each other
so all estimates need to presume given a
well form team of a certain size another
important criteria that is not working
on anything else obviously if you're
giving an estimate saying it's gonna
take three months I say awesome I expect
it in three months by the way I need you
to also do support on this and
professional services with that client
and and and you know it's not going to
be ready in three months where 90
percent of that three months I'm not
actually working on the thing so well
form team not working on anything else
and now here's the last important piece
all estimates have first of all a
confidence level and a range so given a
well formed team of X that is not
working on anything else I am 90%
confident he will take anywhere between
three and 12 months that is a
well-formed estimate that communicates a
lot more than it'll be ready in three
months it'll be ready in 12 months so
that's the first practical thing I want
you to take away next Monday morning you
go back someone asks you for an estimate
this is the format that you use again
you might have that problem where
business is saying I didn't hear any of
that all I heard was it's gonna be ready
in three months so that's the tricky bit
of sort of the trust in the
communication between business and IT
but at least for your part make sure you
write down these estimates and send it
cc'd to your boss and all the necessary
people say that is my estimate and that
is what the architect role does on the
IT side of things this is what we can do
in order to help change the management
of software product development so we go
give these estimates and business
stakeholders will hear that and
hopefully actually listen and engage
with us properly and say you know what
that range is too broad three to 12
months how can I make decisions
based on that they're kind of saying
maybe it's gonna cost me a million
dollars maybe it's gonna cost me four
million dollars that's way too broad a
range at which point in time you can
counter that say well if you give me a
couple of days to do some
proof-of-concept work I can try a bunch
of things out and hopefully I can give
you a tighter estimate say two days yeah
sure go ahead and you come back after
two days and give them some new estimate
we're saying now I'm 90% confident it's
gonna take anywhere between 10 to 12
months they're like oh crap I was hoping
you'd say anywhere between 3 and 4
months based on the previous estimate
that you gave me but again through this
you're communicating that confidence of
now you might get a pushback that says
so before you said you could do it in
three months can you do it
you response in that case when someone
tries to ping you down to a certain
number is to respond once again in the
front saying given a well formed team of
this size that is not working on
anything else I am 10 percent confident
that it will be done in three months in
other words I 90 percent confident that
we will fail doing it in 3 months now if
someone says do it anyway you can't
really stop them but at least you've
done your part to communicate the risk
that's associated with that so
ultimately you go through this cycle
enough times of saying you know give me
some time to do a proof of concept a
bigger proof of concept until such point
in time in the business as you know what
will go for it based on that estimate
you know 6 to 12 months 10 to 12 months
we'll do it at which point in time
congratulations now you have a
requirement where the business knows how
much this thing is going to cost knows
what the benefit is going to be and
they're like awesome now this is where
again things can get dicey so they'll
turn around and say oh so it'll be ready
by
X watch out for that just because some
things are requirement and you provided
an estimate that does not immediately
translate to a schedule why because most
importantly when you look at the
schedule you've already committed to a
whole bunch of other previous
requirements on all of those other
estimates so you've got a backlog of ten
big things that have already been
accepted and are part of your schedule
so in the business set so it'll be ready
at the end of you the year your response
is yes it will be at ready at the end of
year 2025 like whoa sorry what you said
twelve months like yeah but we've got a
whole bunch of other five years of work
that we need to get through first this
is when they start pulling out the so
you want more developers and you got to
watch out for that because they're gonna
try to force you into this place saying
well if I had more developers than maybe
we could get it done faster remember the
first constraint a well formed team
saying if you give me more developers
that means for the next three months I'm
actually going to be slowing down while
I'm onboarding the new people and at
that point in time yeah maybe we'll be
able to deliver stuff faster but it'll
take a while until that actually catches
up and no that's not going to change
2025 to the end of the year so
ultimately the only way to solve this
promise for the business to reprioritize
the order in which we work on things to
say okay build Y before you go and build
X now this is the fun part of our jobs
because we just kind of say look these
are the constraints it's physics so if
you want to change the order in which we
do things we're cool with that as long
as there isn't some substantial
architectural dependency between things
now this is the point in time when you
begin to realize
that the business is not one monolithic
thing it's a bunch of competing fiefdom
that each of them is trying to get their
stuff to go first so you just kind of
say hey you guys reprioritize the
requirements and we'll do whatever you
want and they need to sort of sit back
and watch the dog fight it's just going
back and forth no matter the meeting is
over and your schedule has not been
changed like okay we're gonna keep on
doing our work that we've already got
scheduled from before and whenever you
got an agreement on how we're gonna
repair it says the requirements just let
us know but through this model
eventually you can come up with the new
dates that are going to finalize
everything and say all right this is
what we're doing this is how we're going
to be doing it and get to the point
where broadly speaking all of the
business stakeholders will sign off on
that new schedule now some of you might
be looking at this as moody looks kind
of waterfall II to me we kind of do this
big requirements thing and then we do an
architecture thing and then we do a
scheduling power design thing where's
the agile the agile is the software
development that is happening in
parallel to all of this this is what
feeds our backlogs this is what makes
sure that we have the time and the
political cover to work well to not do
all sorts of pragmatic shortcuts to try
to get things done on time so this is a
parallel product management process to
the regular agile software development
that we're doing and helps keep the rest
of our team's neutralised from all of
the craziness that's happening in the
business world and that's the difficult
change for most software development
organizations to make
but the thing is I don't think that
there's really many options that are
left anymore for organizations because
those prehistoric management techniques
they just don't cut it the business
stakeholders coming in and saying do
this and do that and just kind of a
throwing code against the wall and
seeing if it'll work it hasn't worked
for the past 20 30 years that we've been
in this game it's unlikely to magically
start working now so we need to start
changing things and a lot of these
practices that I've been talking about
are things that we can push as software
developers as tech leads bottom up into
our organization you don't need to be
the CEO you don't need to be the
development manager in order to pull a
lot of this stuff off you just need some
of that you know tenacity to say well
you know this is my estimate this is how
its structured this is my degree of
confidence this is how likely I think
this thing is going to fail and once you
can change that sort of management
philosophy in the company only then can
some of the new technologies though the
AI and the blockchain and all of that
you know quantum computing stuff that
you read about in the news only then is
there some chance that these things
might actually make a difference to our
organizations but the thing that we
still have to contend with even with all
of the great technology that we want to
put into play is the technical debt we
got a whole lot of legacy that we're
dragging behind us and that whole idea
of saying well we're gonna do a rewrite
you know we mentioned that that doesn't
really work we need to have a more
practical set of guidelines to deal with
the coupling of all of the types of
systems that we've got now we've been
trying to fight this coupling in the
layered architecture for pretty much
since the layered architecture came on
the scene and a lot of the times we're
like well ok so we had UI business logic
down that wasn't
decoupled enough let's put an API layer
in the middle and then we still have
coupling they're like okay let's put
some DDD services on top of the business
logic layer and then you know we still
have lots of coupling and we keep adding
more and more layers believing that you
know I think seven layers might not have
been enough but nine you know three
squared I think I think that'll be the
ticket this time for sure so that top to
bottom coupling it's something again
we've been fighting it forever what I
propose to you is to say we've been
fighting the wrong fight and we kind of
need to accept that top to bottom
coupling that's in there and in some
ways kind of get a little bit zen about
it except the coupling be one with the
coupling allow it to kind of seep in and
say all right the issue here is not that
we don't have enough layers but that
we've been looking for the decoupling in
the wrong places there are other places
that if you kind of look around you
might see that one piece of the UI is
fairly decoupled from another piece of
the UI and one piece of business logic
is fairly decoupled from another piece
of business logic and some part of the
database is kind of way over there and
doesn't really have any relationships to
another part of the database in other
words we can start kind of shuffling
stuff around within a given layer and
say you know I think that the decoupling
is not layered but it's sliced these top
to bottom things where parts of the UI
are decoupled from others but each of
them is coupled to their underlying API
in their underlying business logic and
once we do that you know this actually
might work but what that means in
practice is that it's not just pieces of
the UI it's actually to the level of a
single screen even I mean think about it
we got this information for a given page
that's showing us a single item and
we've got information like the
name of the item the image of the item
things like that and then we got the
price and then we got the inventory we
looked at sale hmm
beyond all of them being on the same
page together are there really
meaningful elements of coupling between
them in other words is the business
gonna give us a requirement that says if
the product has more than twenty
characters in its name then its price
must be at least twenty dollars might be
sittin you're thinking that's a stupid
idea who would ever come up with the
requirement like that and that is
exactly the trick say that there are
these pieces of data that just
coincidentally happen to sit on the same
page and that sort of verbally are
associated with the same noun a product
has a name a product has a description a
product has a price a product as an
inventory but there actually isn't any
meaningful logical relationship between
them so we could take that and say you
know what if we took that and both of
the UI level and all the way to the data
level we said hey take the product
catalog stuff and put that in one
vertical slice and take the price and
put that in another vertical slice and
take the ratings and put that in another
vertical slice and take the inventory
and put that in another vertical slice
because every time we talk to the
business about the possibility of
linking these two things they kind of
look at us and say you must be smoking
something right hey you cannot have a
product that costs more than twenty
dollars that will have less than twenty
units of inventory there's another dumb
idea that the business is never going to
want all of those I call them empty
requirements give us an indication about
how we can slice the system down the
middle and a lot of times that slice
actually really does go down the middle
of an entity where one part of an entity
is in one slice in other parts of the
entity are in other slices
the traditional way that you might have
heard about microservices and that kind
of stuff we're saying alright we're
gonna have a product service and then
we're gonna have the customer service
and we're gonna have an order service
and having a service for each entity it
doesn't really work very well because
you need to have lots of calls between
them in order to get anything done but
if you put the product name in one place
and the price in another place you often
don't need as a part of a single
transaction to touch both of those
things together so if we carry this
forward see it's not only true for a
single item page it's also true for even
a list or a grid of items that we're
looking at fundamentally it's the same
thing where the images and names are
coming from one vertical slice and the
ratings are coming from another vertical
slice and the price is coming from
another vertical slice and in essence we
can have this kind of high level data
ownership such that each service has UI
pieces and each service has back-end
pieces and each service has a database
and you know what may be the databases
are even different technologies they
don't all have to be the same we can
have different architectures for each
one of those things depending on the
specific requirements and we can take
that and also include some bit of
synchronization and composition not just
in the front-end but in the back end
with a loosely coupled pub/sub type
model now I know a lot of this kind of
sometimes like ok I get it makes sense
but I still don't exactly see how to put
that into practice and is it really
possible to have that level of
decoupling between services I mean is it
really so bad to have services share
data with each other and in my
experience the problem is that initial
perception usually when we think of
services sharing data kind of like ok
it's you know different services if you
have kids when they're kind of eating
cake around this age three to five years
old yeah they make a mess but it's
mostly harmless but
the reality of this kind of data
shearing and coupling between services
isn't so cute and cuddly as pictures of
somebody's kids instead the reality ends
up looking a little bit more like this
with all sorts of electrical lines going
from one place to the other sending
signals back and forth and you touch
something over here and something
somewhere else that you did not imagine
as related to it starts to break in
other words if you share data between
these services if you create that kind
of coupling between things you're just
creating a distributed big ball of mud
rather than a local big ball of mud and
usually the distributed big ball of muds
are worse because they actually perform
a lot worse because you got all those
HTTP calls going back and forth between
them so ultimately the thing that we're
looking for and I know that sometimes
you're like god there's just no way
there's no way to divide things up so
that we get that clean level of
separation between services that they
don't share data
I got it I've been doing this a long
time I've seen it in a bunch of
different domains it is possible to have
that level of autonomy and ownership and
loose coupling between services we are
not passing data around and when you
find it it's kind of one of those things
you're like oh my god it's obvious how
did I not see it before but like so many
things it's only obvious in retrospect
so that's the hard work for us as
architects is not to take those
shortcuts and to take the extra bit of
time in business analysis to find out
how exactly are we going to be carving
up our entities into different places so
that things don't need to get shared and
if you're able to do that well and get
the organization to execute on that when
you put that stuff into practice there
will be that feeling of oh yeah so I
hope I've given you some ideas of what
is possible what are the things
to do in terms of estimates estimation
what are the things not to do at the
least in terms of architecture and
hopefully I've interested you enough to
want to come to my next talk we're
together we will rule the galaxy thank
you all very much and I hope to see you
in my next talk
[Applause]